foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar efficient
and Rapid discovery of Novel temperature
sensitive alleles with the Onyx digital
genome engineering platform
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by inscripta to learn more visit
inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Randy Lacey PhD senior scientist at
inscripta Randy you may now begin your
presentation
okay thanks for the introduction
um so today I'm going to be talking with
you all about the work I've done using
the Onyx digital genome engineering
platform to identify novel temperature
sensitive alleles
so first I just want to start with a
brief outline of the talk
um first I'll go through an introduction
to temperature sensitive or TS alleles
in the Onyx genome engineering platform
I'll then go into the experimental
approach I took and how I identified and
validated novelty of soils lastly I'll
conclude where the Project's at thus far
and where we're hoping to take it in the
future
so starting with uh introduction to TS
alleles and Onyx so what are what are TS
alleles
tsos are mutations and essential genes
that allow for growth at permissive
temperatures but restrict growth at
non-permissive temperatures so on the
right here I have a pretty simple
example of a yeast spot plating assay
where the top panel shows growth at a
permissive temperature and when that
temperature is shifted to a
non-permissive temperature you get
essentially no growth and this is due to
a single point mutation in in the yeast
genome
so TS alleles are very very effective
tools that are widely used in academic
settings and also have use in industrial
settings
in academic settings TS alleles are
function as genetic tools for studying
essential genes in many different
organisms so I have a couple examples
here I wanted I wanted to share of
Publications that TS alleles were
Central to so on the the top panel this
is a publication in pnas from 1971 in
which a TS allele in a fruit fly in the
cell cycle a cell cycle Gene of the
fruit fly was shown to have very
substantial effects on the behavioral
function of fruit flies as temperatures
increased so this is 1971. Fast Forward
50 years to another publication in pnas
that was published earlier this year
where a TS allele was critical in
understanding the function of or how
methylation is involved in ribosomal
function
so I chose these two because they're
both high-profile Publications separated
by 50 plus years of uh 50 plus years of
research just to highlight that TS
alleles have been relevant for a long
time if you dig through the literature
you'll find many high-profile
Publications where where ATS allele was
was critical to the findings of of that
study
so an industry TS alleles are have a
slightly different function so so in in
a bioindustrial context where we're
always looking for new potential
um tool bioindustrial tools to help aid
um the goals that that we're trying to
achieve so in the context of TS alleles
a a specific example in which they could
be useful is in small molecule
production
so oftentimes organisms like yeast and E
coli are used in are used for production
of small molecules and those in the
production of those molecules are often
linked to Central metabolism
Central metabolism has several essential
genes associated with it so you can
imagine and during small molecule
production where intermediates of
central metabolism are shunted toward
the production of a compound of Interest
a TS allele could function as sort of a
control switch allowing for that
intermediate to instead instead of
continuing through Central metabolism it
can then be shunted toward production of
whatever compound that is that that
you're interested in producing so this
example on the right is from a
publication by Amorous in nature in
2016.
where they engineered the yeast genome
um and and inserted an exogenous
production pathway for the production of
pharmacine so you can see it's tightly
linked with Central metabolism and there
are several points throughout this
pathway where essential genes are are
critical to the ultimate production of
pharmacine so incorporating essential
incorporating TS alleles in this pathway
could help to increase Pharmacy in
production
so hopefully I've convinced you that
tsls are important in both Academia and
Industry and so now I'm going to shift
to essentially the the problem with
tsoils and that's and that's that
they're very difficult to identify
so essential genes are because they're
essential they're they're difficult to
modify and many mutations will will
cause lethality in the organism
so
tsos have been used for for many decades
and the sort of traditional original
methods involve random chemical
mutagenesis with just massive phenotypic
screens and so this is was effective
um in in the early days of finding TS
alleles however it's a very low
throughput and time and labor-intensive
process
more recently a method known as diploid
Shuffle was developed in yeast and so
the the outline of diploid Shuffle seen
here on the right
and so basically this is this is an
error-prone PCR based random mutagenesis
method and so there have been a few uh
tslo collections that have been
generated from uh from diploid Shuffle
which so it's it is a effective method
for identifying TS alleles however it
does have limitations
the first being a starting strain that
is locked in that you have to use for
for using uh for using diploid Shuffle
so there's not much
um there's there's not much space to uh
to use different strains of of yeast in
this context
the second main limitation is you end up
with a point mutation and an essential
Gene that is flanked by uh by selectable
markers so there's there's quite a bit
of genomic modification going on here
that could have
um alone have potential physiological
effects that might make it difficult to
identify the specific effect of your TS
allele
there have also been predictive methods
so so computational methods that um that
have sort of varying efficacy but these
methods are largely limited by the
existing pool of of TS alleles so all of
this begs the question
um what are alternative tools for
generating these these useful useful
tools in biology so we know that TS
alleles have relevance throughout many
different areas of of biology so how can
we more efficiently identify them
so that now brings me to the Onyx
digital genome engineering platform so
Onyx is essentially how I went from
having never used TS alleles in in uh in
my research and had very little
knowledge of them to identifying many
novel TS alleles and only a short uh a
short period of time so a few months at
most
um so now I'm just going to walk you
through the basics of of the Onyx
platform and then and then I'll go
through a sort of example of what an
onyx workflow looks like
so Onyx is a benchtop platform as you
can you can see here and it allows for
scalable and precise genome Engineering
in both yeast and E coli
so part of what's so appealing about
Onyx is um is the Simplicity of the
workflow so
um essentially all you need is an
overnight culture of your yeast or E
coli strain of interest you put the
overnight culture in the instrument
Press Start and within a few days you
have a highly diverse highly edited pool
of of cells as as the output of of an
onyx run
um another unique aspect of Onyx is this
covalently linked guide RNA donor DNA
and barcode DNA system that drives the
genomic editing but it's also highly
trackable
um with a DNA barcode so you can so you
can follow the sort of progress of uh of
your specific edit designs throughout
the lifetime of a of an experiment or
project
so now looking at the uh just a basic
example of of the Onyx workflow so Onyx
allows for iterative cycles of the
design generate test learn cycle of
synthetic biology and it starts with
design
so the Onyx inscripta and scripta
Engineering software allows allows for
designs in both yeast and E coli so so
edit designs in
Sacramento you can have you can have up
to 6 000 designs per library and
saccharomyces and you can have up to ten
thousand designs per library in E coli
and you can and these designs can be can
be quite varied so you can you can make
one to 63 base pair
um uh edits and these can be insertions
deletions or or substitutions
so once you've once you've settled on
your on your specific design Library the
next step is to actually build it all
right so or or to generate it and this
is done on the actual Onyx instrument so
so after your build you end up with a
pooled
um a pooled Cell live engineered cell
library and so from this cell library
you can then go directly into into uh
phenotyping so and the phenotyping
strategies can either be screening or or
selection selection approaches
so with with your engineered cell
library you can also sort of assess
um assess the the makeup of the library
using a series of NGS assays that
include both a barcode diversity assay
and two different whole genome edit
detection assays and so these give you
an idea of the diversity of edits or the
diversity of designs present in in your
engineered cell library and also the
fraction of those cells that are that
are have the edit the intended Onyx edit
so as you're going through this test uh
the the test stage of the design
generate test learn cycle so you'll be
going through you'll perform your
screenings and selections and the next
step is to actually learn from them and
so you can learn from uh your you can
learn from the screening and selections
using on using the inscriptor resolver
software so in scripter resolver just
takes the NGS data either from your
engineered cell library or after
screening and selections and provides an
analysis of the makeup of your of your
cell libraries
so that completes the cycle and then now
so now you've learned about how your
edits have behaved when when you've
applied specific selective pressures
from from your screen or or from your
selection so from there you can use that
information to iterate again through
this cycle and learn more and more each
each time you go through
so at this point
um I'm going to shift gears um and and
focus on how I use Onyx to identify
novel temperature sensitive alleles but
before I do that I just want to briefly
mention that Onyx is a is a very
powerful and versatile platform that's
not just for engine that's not just for
identifying TS alleles it's it's it has
very broad use in in research
communities and it's it's particularly
powerful in in the context of strain
development so for for optimizing small
molecule production and protein
production and just in general and
genome Discovery so so identifying those
underlying hidden aspects of the genome
that we otherwise wouldn't be able to
wouldn't be able to study or understand
um so now I want to merge back from Onyx
into TS alleles and sort of
um
present and I represent the basics of
how Onyx provides advantages over the
over methods like diploid Shuffle or or
similar methods um similar methods to
that
so the first is that Onyx Onyx allows
for very specific trackable genomic
edits with with very minimal
modifications so you only have the
intended edit that that you're
interested in this is on essential genes
um you get it from Onyx you get your
engineered cell library which is just a
pool output and this can go directly
into screens and selections and you can
also make a variety of edits and tags so
so it's not just single single point
mutations if if you think that a
specific tag can have a temperature
sensitive effect you can you can use
that as well it's also efficient in both
yeast and and potentially any E coli so
you don't you're not limited by a
particular saccharomyces cerevisiae
strain you can have you can generate
tsos in any of your service strains of
Interest
so just to wrap up the introduction I
want to go over the the main project
goals
um and so the the first is is pretty
simple it's just to identify novel TS
alleles in yeast and E coli
um using using the Onyx platform to do
this and so this presents new tools in
the form of Novel TS alleles for both
Academia and Industry and also
highlights the effectiveness of Onyx in
this context
the second is to identify potential
Trends in TS allele loci so from a from
a first pass of of identifying novelty
as alleles we I want to be able to take
identify potential Trends in um and
where those TSL are located and and
learn from that and develop a more
potential rational design strategy for
for identifying uh TS alleles in in the
future
okay now I'm gonna walk you through the
experimental approach I took to identify
these novel TS alleles using uh using
the Onyx platform
so the first step in this process is
Library design so I've generated four or
designed four different libraries three
in yeast and one E coli the first two
yeast libraries Target one gene each so
the first targets dihydrofolate
reductase which is involved in folate
biosynthesis and has no known TS alleles
the second targets M13 which is involved
in heme biosynthesis so the next two
gene or the next two libraries targeting
yeast in E coli are related to one
another the yeast Gene targets 10
different essential genes that have nine
nine of which have orthologs that are
essential genes in E coli so I'm hoping
using using these two libraries to
identify trends that um Trends and TSL
loci that course that correspond across
across kingdoms so so
um loci that that produce tsoles and
yeast and also an E coli
so Central
um a key component of each of these
libraries are these internal uh positive
TS allele controls so any in in yeast I
have three different uh controls that
produce published TS alleles and in E
coli there's four different positive
controls that produce published TS
alleles as well
um so from here I'm just going to focus
on the on the yeast libraries I I've
I've not gotten as much work done in the
E coli Library
um yet but I'm hoping to get get to that
in the future but but for now I'll just
just focus on the uh on the yeast
libraries
so the edit types that make up each of
these libraries are are are pretty
important so so dfr1 and M13 libraries
are are somewhat similar they both have
about 6 000 designs in them
um half of those designs are are
predominantly single amino acid
substitutions which you can see how that
have that edit Works down here with the
examples of edit types the other half
are triple amino acid substitutions and
again this is three amino acids
replacing three amino acids the rest of
the library is composed of stop codons
synonymous edits and those internal TS
allele controls I mentioned before
and so you can see that there's about
200 internal tslo controls and the way
that I populated out the three designs
to 2 to 200 is using a variety of Pam
spacers that are going to actually
create these edits
the 10 Gene libraries is slightly
different there's about 480 single amino
acid substitutions per Gene that Target
each gene no triple amino acid
substitutions and then about 30 stop
codons and 30 synonymous edits and a
reduced number of TSL controls too so
that I can have a bit more single amino
acid substitutions that are actually
targeting targeting the genes
so this is the design I've now designed
each of these three libraries now the
next step is to actually generate and or
or build these libraries on onyx so so
so make the libraries produce an
engineered cell library and begin
understanding what the makeup of the
population of those edited cells is so
that's um that's what this this data
here in the top shows the pooled edit
fraction for each Library the pooled
edit CV and also the isolate edit
fraction
so for each Library the edit rate is
above above 50 which is which is uh
really really strong editing the pooled
edit CV is somewhat skewed for for these
libraries and that that was expected we
are making edits in in essential genes
so there's going to be lots of uh
designs that are likely to drop out as
these are going to be the lethal lethal
mutations for uh for the essential genes
that that they're targeting
so we can also look at the actual design
representation and that's what that's
what this plot is showing down here so
these are each of the um these represent
each of the actual barcodes that are
associated with the designs split up
into the the type of edits that those
designs are um are supposed to make and
then plot it as log 10 design
representation
and so the most of the each of these
designs are hovering around as are
hovering around zero for log 10 design
representation aside from the stop
codons which which makes sense they
should in theory be depleting as these
uh lots of stop codons are probably
going to have lethal effects when they
target when they target these genes
so overall these are really great
editing and diversity metrics and each
of these pool of cells is now
um is can now go into the the test phase
so how can we start applying how can we
start testing these libraries and
applying selective pressures to pull out
interesting edits that are potentially
making
um making TS alleles
so what we're looking at here is just a
basic flowchart of how I perform the
selection strategy so I have three
biological replicates where I have a
sort of a pre-growth of a specific
amount of cells at 25c and so the actual
number of cells is important here
because we don't want to bottleneck our
population we want to make sure that
we're starting with a diverse number of
designs that can all be exposed to to
The Selective pressures and and we can
hopefully pull out information about
them at the end of the experiment
so throughout the throughout the
selection process
um we'll have an initial pre-growth at
25c this is then divided into 25c 35c
with with the uh the rest the remaining
amount of these cells going to DNA
extraction with barcode sequencing
um we then grow these to saturation
which is about six generations and
repeat this process for for Generation 6
12 18 and 24 and at each of these points
we're taking
um taking samples for DNA extraction and
barcode sequencing so we what we what
we're doing here is sequencing the
barcodes and getting an idea of how
they're behaving over time at each of
these time points are they enriching are
they depleting or is or is not much
happening to them and and from there we
can get information about whether or not
they're actually behaving similar to um
to known TS alleles
so now that we've tested our Onyx
libraries by applying selective
pressures the next thing we want to do
is start learning learning from that so
what um what happened to our designs
over time as as they as they grew it at
different temperatures
so to do this we take those barcode read
counts and essentially look at how how
they increase or decrease over to over
the life of the experiment
and so we analyze these barcode barcode
read counts using this software package
called enrich2 so software or enrich two
is a software tool that can provide
statistical analysis for count based
experiments similar similar to what um
what we're looking at here so the main
output of enrich 2 are scores that
indicate whether or not a design
enriched or depleted in the population
over time
so what we're looking at down here is
the basic output of of enrich two so
each of these plots represent One Design
where each point is the log ratio that
corresponds to read counts of that
specific design barcode recounts of that
specific design over time and and the
bottom axis is is uh time points and
generations so looking at this first
design here not much happened to it so
the the slope the slope of this of this
design is is essentially zero at this
point so so it's enrich two score is
zero didn't enrich or deplete
on the right we see that this design
very specifically depletes over over the
course of the experiment so it gets an
enriched 2 score of negative 2.19
so that's a so this design depletes
you also get lots of statistical
analyzes
um like p-values false Discovery rates
and things like that that can help you
sort of have confidence in these in
these enriched two scores that that are
produced for each design
so this plot that we're looking at here
is all of these enriched two scores that
you get for every design
um uh in in a specific experiment
plotted against the log 10 p-value so
you can see all right what's the enrich
two score
um and is is that score actually
statistically significant across
biological replicates so you get a
pretty interesting spread of how all of
the designs behaved at specific
temperatures throughout the life of an
experiment
so now let's get into the um the actual
data from from our library so from the
dfr1 M13 and 10 Gene libraries
so each of these plots are just XY plots
showing the x-axis with the 25 degree C
enrich two scores and the vertical axis
is the 35c enrich 2 scores
and so this is each design in in the uh
in the entire library and so these are
all the average the each of these scores
is the average of three biological
replicates so just looking at these
plots you can see for most of the
designs most of them have scores that
for both both temperatures hover around
zero right so that's that's not entirely
unexpected that a lot of these mutations
aren't going to have a substantial
effect on on the on how these designs
behave throughout the course of the
experiment so what we're interested in
in particular are designs that have not
much of an effect at zero or not much of
an effect at 25 degrees C so they're
kind of hovering around zero and they're
depleting at 35c right so so sort of
we're looking for designs that are in
this this fourth quadrant here and so
these are these are
um uh mutations that are likely causing
uh temperature sensitive alleles
so in order to
um in order to start identifying these
we and are identifying putative TS
alleles
we use the internal known TS allele
controls that I mentioned before so just
a reminder these are the actual
mutations down here and each of the the
colors here correspond to the designs
that are the internal TS allele controls
on each plot
so the first thing that kind of that's
that's that stood out to me when looking
at this was how similar across each of
these experiments these known TS alleles
behave so so this this provided a lot of
confidence in our actual selection
strategy because these are all
independent selections performed um
performed at different times
so as as I mentioned before we're
looking we want designs that are that
are hovering around 0-25c and are
depleting at 35c and you can see that
the mge1 and ala1 Designs are very
strongly depleting at 35c with with
minimal effect at at 25c
hsp10 has has a bit of a lesser effect
so so TS alleles are they're they're
they're very sensitive to the conditions
of the experiment so so they can behave
like TS alleles in certain contexts but
but not others so it's not entirely it's
not entirely surprising that this is um
that this is not quite as strong of an
effect as the other as the other two
designs
so this was this was a great first step
but we're just qualitatively looking at
how these designs are behaving what we
want is to actually extract quantitative
information so that we can start
predicting what are these other designs
that aren't known TS alleles that are
sort of behaving like known TS alleles
and and how can we how can we
quantitatively decide which ones to to
start targeting
um uh for for potential validation
so here again the the internal controls
are are functioning as a guide for
screening putative TS alleles in each
Library
so what I did was just a simple
calculation where I took the score I
subtracted the 35 C and Rich 2 score
from the 25c enrich 2 score for all of
the designs that are making each of
these in internal controls and average
average that value and then I did the
same thing for all of the designs that
are that are targeting um our genes of
Interest whether dfr1 M13 or the 10 Gene
Library
and so what these values show is that
there's there's a sort of a strong
they're mostly strong positive scores
whereas the actual Target edits aren't
having quite as much of an effect which
again makes sense visually when you when
when looking at at the plots
so with these with these values in mind
I wanted to next start to see which of
these Target Edits edits are actually
behaving
um at least at least similar if not
better than all of our internal known TS
allele controls
so I filtered out all of the target
edits from from each library that had a
25c minus 35c enrich 2 score of greater
than three so so better than average for
all of the internal controls and these
are the numbers that that we pulled out
so for dfr1 there's 85 designs that meet
this criteria M13 there's 188 in the 10g
library there's 123. so what this does
is it provides a starting point for
um for screening this this TS phenotype
so so these can be with this this many
of these designs might not actually be
tsos and we might lose some there might
be some with scores less than this that
RTS alleles but this is a good a good
starting point and so we also with these
with these designs we want to also take
into account the statistical
significance so make make sure that
these aren't just just
um random hits that that fall into this
category these are actually significant
um and and likely to be functioning like
TS alleles
so just to just to actually
qualitatively visualize how these hits
look
um when when when plotted so as expected
these are all of the hits so so the each
of the green dots are one of those one
of those hits that I just mentioned
and so they all fall into this this
fourth quadrant sort of hovering around
zero 25 and depleting substantially um
at 35. and so this becomes a bit more
visually striking when when looking When
comparing volcano plots between 25c and
Rich two scores
um compared to 35c enrich two scores
where you can see each of the green dots
which is which is one of these putative
hits
um is is very very much depleting
um when you when you show these plots at
35c compared to 25c so this is a I
thought was a really striking
representation to how each of these
designs are behaving in in this pool of
cells throughout the throughout the
lifetime of this experiment
um okay so this is this was essentially
finding screening identifying what are
what what designs are potentially
behaving like TS alleles in these
libraries
so now the next step is to actually
validate these so so determine if these
are in fact producing a uh producing a
TS phenotype so there's there's a couple
different ways to approach this um and
I'll get into that um when we when we
get to the conclusions but the first
step I wanted to take was just to
manually recreate a few of these sort of
top hits from from each of these
libraries
um so this is um I just wanted to it's
it's a kind of a convoluted process for
for producing uh for reproducing these
these TS alleles that we identified so
this is um this is just the process for
individual validation of of these tsoil
hits and this this is in progress at
this point
so the first step is to choose what what
I think were the sort of top hits that
meet the the score criteria and the
statistical criteria as well and so use
these these cassettes that contain our
our guide RNA donor DNA and and barcode
DNA transform those with the
inscriptoplasmid into a and into our um
sacrament
pick colonies screened them before the
actual presence of the edit so make sure
that the edit is is in the colonies we
screen
and then the next step from here is to
cure out the Onyx plasm from miso so we
want we want only the only the edit
present in the genome
so the next step after that you have a
you have an isolated cured edited
saccharomyces or visier cell that has
your potential TS allele so then start
screening it so so perform initial
growth assays that permissive and
non-permissive temperatures and these
can this can be in liquid these can be
on plates there's a variety of ways to
approach this and then the last step is
to actually confirm these TS TS
phenotypes and and explore the the
potential basis for for what's what's
driving this um the biological basis for
what's driving this TS phenotype so as I
said this this isn't work in progress
I've I've begun screening the M13 some
of the top hits from the the M13 Library
thus far using using a spot plating
approach
so here are the results from a spot
plating assay just looking at six of
these sort of top TS allele
um designs
um and so on the left we see we see a
spot planning Essay with growth at 22
degrees C and then on the right is
growth at 37 degrees C and so of these
of these six designs that we've screened
thus far we see two two of these so
about 33 1 3 or 33 percent of the
designs are showing a really strong TS
allele phenotype and this is um this is
super interesting and we're starting to
dig into put the potential biological
basis basis for this right now so this
is this is a really exciting point in in
the project
okay so the the last section is just the
conclusions and and future work so so
what what are we what have we learned
thus far from from this project and and
where are we hoping to go with it from
here so the main conclusion at this
point is that Onyx is Onyx provides a
very rapid and efficient platform for
identifying novelty as alleles so so I'm
still the the actual validation is still
a work in progress but but the hit rate
at one third hit rate is is pretty high
and so this is um and only over like a
couple month period so this is a this
has been a pretty pretty awesome
experience to to start identifying these
novelty as alleles
so for future work the the biggest
question we have right now is how can we
increase
um the efficiency of identifying or of
validating these TS alleles so so
manually build rebuilding each of these
designs is is pretty time intensive and
laborious so we're brainstorming ideas
of how we can how we can sort of
increase the rate of this so one idea we
have is to um is to actually make Onyx
validation libraries so from those 6000
designs pick the top 100 to 200 designs
um from from that that represent the the
represent putative TS a little hits and
then make another Onyx library that only
has those uh build those designs on onyx
and isolate and Screen colonies directly
directly from Onyx as opposed to going
through the full selection
um the full selection experiment again
so we already know that these are we
already know how these are behaving in
that context
and then we can and then we can directly
screen these on a plate or in 96 well
liquid base growth assays
so that's that leads into the the second
sort of
um uh the second component of this is
optimizing these growth assays so so TS
alleles are not are not on or off it's
not growth or not there's there's
oftentimes a intermediate growth effects
that can be quite difficult to pull out
when you're um or or to observe when
you're screening many many different
isolates
so we're hoping to develop assays that
are sensitive enough to pick up on
growth defects that happen at
non-permissive temperatures compared to
permissive temperatures
we also want to perform the Selections
in E coli so so the E coli libraries
comparing them with with yeast libraries
will be really interesting to see if we
get similar hits or if we get the hits
at sort of conserved sites across across
each of these genes
and that that leads into the the final
uh the final point of of the future work
is and and this is the the second part
of the project goals and that's to
identify or investigate Trends in
predicted TS allele loci so this this
can help to Aid in more rational design
strategies so I've started to dig into
this data a little bit thus far I
noticed early on that many of these top
hits that we've identified
were clustering to a small subset of
amino acids in either dfr1 or in hem13
so what I what I've plotted here is just
a rank ordered amino acid position based
on the number of predicted
um uh or of putative TS alleles that um
that are that Target that specific amino
acid and so that's that's what we're
looking at for for both of these plots
so for dfr1 over 50 of those 88
predicted uh TS alleles our Target
Target only six amino acids out of 211.
and for him 13 about 50 percent of the
predicted TS alleles are found in only
19 amino acids and him 13 has 300 plus
amino acids
so this is this is a very very
interesting observation and and really
suggests that there are specific loci or
specific residues that are more or less
amenable to forming TS alleles
so the next question we have at this
point is what what it what about these
residues are are particularly
interesting
so are they are they highly conserved or
are they not conserved at all Are there
specific structural features that Define
them that that make these residues more
able to form uh temperature sensitive
alleles or their functions is it
something about the function of dfr1 and
M13 that's that's driving this
and ultimately as I've mentioned already
can can these features inform rational
design strategies for identifying TS
allele so can we take information from
this from this learning step of of the
cycle and allow that to inform the next
sort of iteration of of the of an onyx
experiment where we can have more
rational design strategies where where
instead of having random amino acids
throughout the entire protein
uh random amino acids substitutions
throughout the entire protein we have a
few targeted amino acids that we know
are going to be more likely to
um to form TS alleles so this is this is
again a work in progress but it's but
these observations are are really
interesting and we're hoping really
hoping to to learn a lot from them
um so with that I'd like to thank you
all for listening and I'll take any
questions
thank you Randy for your info and fourth
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
if you wanted to find temperature
sensitive alleles across many genes how
could you do this with the Onyx
instrument with a limitation of 6 000
designs in yeast
thanks Kaylee
um yeah so this this kind of gets that
to this gets at the sort of last point I
was making there and and trying to
identify rational design strategies so
so I in the libraries I designed I
targeted a single Gene and and 10 genes
um and so we're hoping to to learn more
about where the TS alleles are located
on on uh on each of these in each of
these libraries so that we can use that
to make let's say a 30 Gene library or a
50 Gene Library where we don't have to
do a a random scanning random scanning
amino acid substitution so we can use
that to Target only let's say 10 of a
protein with with specific substitutions
that are that are more likely to um that
are more likely to to produce
temperature sensitive uh temperature
sensitive alleles
all right thank you next question
what temperature are the cells at during
editing on the Onyx instrument will some
design edits die off if the cells are
not maintained at the permissive
temperature
yeah so this is uh this is a great Point
um so on onyx editing and growth happens
at 30 degrees Celsius so so this is
um of course an intermediate temperature
to to what I uh to the two temperatures
I was testing both 25 degrees C and and
35 degrees C so
with this in mind it is it's definitely
possible that this intermediate
temperature could cause some of the
designs that make TS Leo that make TS
alleles to sort of drop out of the
population prior to um prior to me
starting a selection experiment but
as I mentioned
um during the introduction the actual
growth um during editing on the
instrument is it's a pretty short period
of time so so it's from the start of the
experiment to the end of an honest
experiment it's only a few days and the
actual process of editing is is only a
fraction of that so it's it's likely
it's definitely possible that that some
of these designs were lost in that
process but it's likely that most of
them will be able to
um will be able to make it through the
um through the entire Onyx editing uh
Earth through an entire Onyx experiment
to the uh to the end so they can
actually start
um and push them into a selection
experiment
all right thank you
um next question there are actually two
parts
um are the barcodes integrated into
chromosomes after genome editing
and is this genome editing protocol with
mad7 scarvis
um yeah so so to answer the first part
um no the barcodes are not integrated
into the chromosomes only the the only
thing that's actually delivered into the
chromosome is is your your edit of
Interest so so the barcodes remain um on
the actual Onyx plasmid
um and to answer the second question is
genome editing protocol with mad 7
scarless so it's
um oftentimes it can be scarless but
there are instances where um sort of
where synonymous edits need to be made
in order to prevent um to prevent
re-cutting so these would be very
minimal modifications that that just
produce um alternate codons
um so so the the the in dot or the the
wild type amino acids are produced but
there are very slight modifications
surrounding your your edit of Interest
all right thank you
next question why did you have to
rebuild edits to validate temperature
edits
um yeah so so
right so all of these edits are are
actually being made um on on the Onyx
instrument so this is in in the case of
a selection experiment it's it's a
pooled um it's a pooled uh assay right
so so all of the designs are mixed
together in in the liquid culture during
uh during a selection assay so they're
so they're not separated so in some
cases for some selection experiments it
would be possible to isolate those
designs at the end of a selection by
simply plating them and screening
isolate colonies for the sort of hits
that you're interested in but this would
require the um the hits from your
selection experiment to be enriching
right so they uh so they have to be sort
of increasing in in the population over
time or or having not much happen to
them basically so I was specifically
interested in in depleting edits in this
case
um so these are going to be very likely
they're very difficult to identify after
are plating this the out or the end uh
the end result of of a selection of a
selection experiment so so as I
mentioned in the in the um future in the
sort of future directions what we're
planning now is so since we've we've
learned from these first um this first
round of uh of uh Tia of Onyx
experiments identify these csls we now
have a general idea of what the
potential hits are so I'm planning to to
actually rebuild those on onyx as
opposed to doing uh building each design
building each design manually
um so build let's say 200 200 edits
plate those and then screen and identify
identify the hits
um from from a sort of isolate screening
isolate screening design after after an
onyx build
all right thank you and we will wrap up
with that question thank you again Randy
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor in scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye